[Music]
do
welcome to the table
i'm thrilled to see um each one of you
guys here um my name is don jacobs i'm
part of the leadership team i'm here at
the table i'm glad that to see so many
faces um so many so many kids i'm still
getting used to the fact there are kids
in this room that's fantastic to see yes
[Laughter]
speaking of kids so we are actually
still i'm going to be doing summer rama
um that's going to be coming up next
month it's going to be
august the 5th and the 6th
and we are still looking for volunteers
um for that
so there is a sign up sheet in the very
back at this back entrance on a table
that's something that you might be
interested in you have the time
the availability or something that
you're even passionate about you and you
want to be able to participate um
brittany would be able to help kind of
guide direct that for you guys
also
this is for anybody who's entering
kindergarten or who has completed sixth
grade so all of our kids are just
welcome to participate in that
um
before we get started just a quick
reminder this is um july so um you know
kind of giving brett uh maggie just a
little bit of a break and so we do have
some guest speakers and i will introduce
our guest speaker for today i'm excited
to introduce her um but so just kind of
a reminder we're just giving them a
little bit of breather so
but if you need anything from our uh
table family um myself part of the
leadership team karen gary were
available if you guys uh just are just
needing anything and so just kind of let
us know
with that i'm just going to open our
worship time with prayer
if you wouldn't mind praying with me
lord just thank you so much for this
time
this ability to come together
to be able to come and to be in a space
where we can just worship you and i pray
you open our hearts and our minds um for
our worship experience and what denise
will be sharing with us later on this
evening
um and i pray that you will just help us
to walk away with a deeper connection
not just to each other but with you as
well in christ and i pray amen
all right you guys we're so glad you're
here um we're gonna start some worship
time together if this is your first time
there is space in room for you and
however you want to engage this so if
that's sitting down and soaking in the
music and the lyrics feel free to do
that if that is standing with us
which let's go ahead and do that right
now for those of you who want to
join in at any point with any of the
songs you don't have to know what you're
singing this is a communal effort it's
not a performance this is a space for us
to engage in truths that we believe
about jesus and the way that he loves us
and the way that he calls us to live
this life together so you're welcome
here and feel at home whatever that
looks like
[Music]
let the king of my heart be the mountain
where
[Music]
is
of my heart be the wind inside myself
[Music]
of my
heart inside myself
is
[Music]
oh
you are good
you're good
[Music]
you're never gonna let me
oh you are good
you're never gonna let me down
[Music]
you are good
you're good
[Music]
you are good
you're good
you are
[Music]
all right thank you guys kids y'all are
dismissed to go to your classrooms and
we will see you after the service
bye shiloh
so
[Music]
god we step into this space together and
just make room for you to do your good
work in us
[Music]
every story
every past
every future it has a place inside of
you
you are the thread that connects us
god so would we feel that connectedness
tonight
would we feel that thread of grace
sewn into our lives
[Music]
god help us to be open to what you're
doing here in this place
give us hearts
that feel
the goodness of god
[Music]
cause you
deserve every piece
[Music]
every piece
cause you
[Music]
lord
i
a am
father and all that you have it
[Music]
is over and over and over again i am
bringing my heart to you with open hands
closer and closer to drawing
[Music]
over and over again
tear down
[Music]
every
won't you come and break through to me
over and
over again i am bringing my heart to you
with open hands closer and closer
[Music]
lay before you
again over and over and over again i am
bringing my heart to you with open hands
closer and closer
[Music]
built
in my heart
[Music]
my
every piece
[Music]
we're going to move into the prayers of
our people and if this is your first
time this is a opportunity for us to
shoulder each other's burdens and we all
walk into this space with different
things that we're carrying people that
are on our hearts or situations
that are burdensome for us and maybe
it's in our own lives or maybe it's in
someone else's
and we just want to acknowledge that god
is with us in our struggles and he wants
to carry those burdens with us and we
want to shoulder those burdens together
for one another so we're going to read
this prayer out loud together and then
there's going to be a section where we
leave some space for each of us to share
a name or a situation that we're
carrying and you can say that out loud
and if you're joining us online you're
welcome to leave that in the comments
and
someone will read those aloud over the
microphone so that we can be a part of
that with you as well
and then i'll finish out the prayer
together with us again
jesus for the city of saxi texas and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and for all who remember
and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us
and so we lift these names and
situations up to you
johnny owen and chelsea
um
still everest
for these names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
[Music]
little
and there's nothing left to do
[Music]
at the feet of jesus
down lay it all down
filled with all those ancient thoughts
all your doubts become your god
lay it all down
[Music]
of
jesus
[Music]
lay it all down lay it all down
lay it all down
[Music]
when we've given up on better days there
are memories
[Music]
there's nothing here that can
the ease of
jesus
[Music]
at the feet of
jesus
come
on lay it all down lay it all down lay
it all down lay it all down
lay it all down lay it all down lay it
all down
[Music]
lay it all down lay it all down lay it
all
[Music]
at the down
of jesus
[Music]
lay it all down
jesus
[Music]
of jesus
yeah we bring all of our burdens all of
our cares and our worries
the anxiety the depression
whatever it is god
that haunts us sometimes we bring those
into this space and we hold it up into
the light knowing
that you are gracious
and you are good
and you are not a god who shames us
or pushes us away but you are a god who
invites us in to your peace
you shoulder our burdens
you carry our pain with us
so god we trust you with those
concerns we trust you with those hurts
knowing god that you will also be with
us
in the moments of joy
you will also be with us
when we sense your light and your peace
and your life flowing through us
god we trust you to continue your good
work in our hearts and in our community
and in this place
and god we choose to carry you with us
we choose to acknowledge
the work of jesus that you're doing
inside of us
and no matter how far we have felt
no matter how tired we are god
we believe in the one
who came
and showed us unconditional love
we believe in jesus
who takes us up out of the pit out of
the muck in the mire and sets our feet
on a rock
and we look to
look to you to do that in our lives
and help us to call that out
for each other to believe that for one
another
that there's a redemption work
going on
we love you we love the way that you
love us god help us to love others that
same way
be with us tonight as we meet here
together it's in your name we pray all
these things
amen
thank you guys for worshiping along with
us
as you sit down if you want to turn to
the people around you welcome them
say hello to each other and we will have
our speaker come up
all right so close again uh so i get the
opportunity to introduce denise to you
guys um and one of the things i will i
want to keep bringing the story up you
know i wasn't here for this part of the
story i don't want to forget about it
because when the table was first trying
to find a space to be in
um you know the people who were trying
to look for a space for us just to kind
of meet to have a safe space to kind of
meet specifically for the way that we
it was just really funny how
passing by this small little church on
the side of the road and they were like
hey let's try out this place and we
looked here
and they met denise
and they felt immediately like oh my
gosh this is where we need to be
and since i've gone to these interested
in one of those this warm and most open
and most welcoming people i've ever met
i'd love that that would be to partner
with with your church pleasant valley um
with all the different things that we do
one of the services has been the most
meaningful of
i've never been participating in one
service ever before in all of my years
ever being been charged my entire life
my entire life
45 years old and so um but that was that
was very special it was very special so
anyway with that being said um denise is
here to share with us come on
[Applause]
thank you i think i would just come back
for the introductions they're always so
wonderful i appreciate it so much
i am so glad to be with you all again i
just love
being with you i love this congregation
i hope you know that
from the moment i called maggie i saw
her email and i called her
i just felt like god was saying
this is supposed to be and so i'm just
very grateful for you all
my
scripture for tonight is a very long one
but it's a good story so we're going to
read it all it is taken from the book of
ruth
and it is chapter 1 verses 1 through 18
so bear with me as we go through this
in the days when the judges ruled there
was a famine in the land
and a certain man of bethlehem and judah
went to live in the country of moab
he and his wife and two sons
the name of the man was a limelech
and the name of his wife naomi and the
names of his two sons were maelon and
killian
they were ephrathites from bethlehem in
judah they went to the country of moab
and remained there but elemelech the
husband of naomi died
and she was left with her two sons
these took moabite wives the name of one
was orpah and the name of the other ruth
and when they had lived there for about
10 years both maelon and killian also
died
so that the women the woman was left
without her two sons or her husband
then she started to return with her
daughters-in-law from the country of
moab for she had heard in the country of
moab that the lord had had consideration
for his people and given them food
so she set out from the place where she
had been living she and her two
daughters-in-law
and they went on their way to go back to
the land of judah
but naomi said to her two
daughters-in-law go back each of you to
your mother's house
may the lord deal kindly with you as you
have dealt with the dead and with me
may the lord grant that you may find
security each of you in the house of
your husband
then she kissed them and they wept aloud
they said to her no we will return with
you to your people
but naomi said turn back my daughters
why will you go with me
do i still have sons in my womb that
they may become your husbands
turn back my daughters go your way for
i'm too old to have a husband even if i
thought there was hope for me even if i
should have a husband tonight and bear
sons
would you then wait until they were
grown
would you then refrain from marrying no
my daughters it has been far more bitter
for me than for you
because the hand of the lord has turned
against me
then they wept aloud again
orpah kissed her mother-in-law but ruth
clung to her
so she said
see your sister-in-law has gone back to
her people and her gods return after
your sister-in-law
but ruth said
do not press me to leave you
or to turn back from following you where
you go i will go where you lodge i will
lodge your people shall be my people
and your god my god
where you die i will die
there i will be buried
may the lord do thus and so to me and
more as well if even death parts me from
you
when naomi saw she was determined to go
with her
she said no more to her
this is god's word for god's people
tonight thanks be to god would you pray
with
come holy spirit
may the words of my mouth and the
meditations of our hearts be acceptable
in your sight
our rock
and our redeemer
amen so when we read a book
a title usually gives us a pretty good
clue as to what the book will be about
though the trend is now towards some
more obscure titles well the classics
are fairly straightforward aren't they
if we pick up a copy of tolstoy's war
and peace well we're fairly certain that
it's going to be about
war and peace
if we pick up harry potter and the
sorcerer's stone we are pretty certain
it's going to be about someone named
harry potter and some kind of sorcerer's
stone
so when we look at the book of ruth most
of us would assume that the story is
about a woman named ruth
but if you listen to the beginning of
the story it almost seems like the
narrator has not received that memo
it says
he doesn't seem to understand that the
book is about someone else
at least according to him
he begins by telling us then the days
when the judges ruled there was a famine
in the land and there was a man named
elimelech who had a wife naomi and two
sons maelon and killian
now it's an interesting story because
they come from bethlehem
which means house of bread
but apparently there was no bread in the
house of bread
and so elimelech had to decide to go
somewhere else somewhere he could find
food for his family
but of all the places he chose to go
well strangely enough elimelech chooses
to go to the country of moab
now
to a place that is
despised
by the israelites
they're considered a hostile nation for
us today moab would be maybe
iran or
north korea
yet this is where elimelech decides to
take his family
to live among
unclean
and hated people
and apparently the decision does not
turn out to be a very good one for
elimelech
and his family because uh he's only
there for two verses
he dies in the third verse
and he leaves his wife naomi and his two
sons maelon and killian behind
now incidentally the names of the two
sons are from hebrew roots that in order
mean disease
and perish
so we get a clue right from the
beginning that the decision was even
worse than we thought at first
and sure enough after marrying two
moabite women will disease in parish do
just as their names suggest
and they leave naomi all alone
she came to this god-forsaken place to
find a better life but
look what happened
everyone she cares about has died and
she's stuck in a country that's not even
her own
i mean she left because god had brought
famine to her land and then then she
hears that after they left god looked
upon the people and gave them all food
the house of bread is once again well
full of bread
it was all for nothing
just her luck she thinks
she's lost everything and she's all
alone
well except for two daughters-in-law
and although they're really nice girls
they'd do anything for her let's face it
they're moabites
so naomi decides to go
home her two daughters-in-law pack her
and themselves up and they all start out
heading for bethlehem
because they're three widows you see
they only have each other
but as soon as they get on the road well
naomi turns to them and says you know
you're both really sweet girls
and i appreciate it and all but i've
been thinking about this and i think
it's best if you just remain here in in
moab
you've been loyal to my sons even after
they've been dead and gone you've been
so good to me in fact you've done more
than anyone would expect
you need to go back to your mom's house
though
find a nice moab man
to marry you
a husband that will take care of you
now it seems that naomi has been
thinking
and she's probably been thinking about
going home with two moabite women in tow
she knows that she's already persona non
grata back in bethlehem because she left
when times got hard
but
not only did she leave she left for moab
but now now that things are good again
she's coming back
it's already going to be humiliating
enough to go home having lost everything
but imagine how much more humiliating it
is to go home if she has two moabite
daughters in law with her even if they
are really nice girls
you know it's really just so much better
for everybody
if they would just stay in moab
but orba and ruth well they don't really
want that to happen
they want to stick together i mean three
women together have a chance but one
with no husband or sons it's a disaster
waiting to happen
so they beg naomi please let us go with
you
well now naomi's getting a little put
out
you need to go home
what good will it do for you to come
with me i've had nothing for you i'm
certainly not going to find another
husband i'm certainly not going to have
any more sons for you to marry you just
need to go home look this is really hard
on me girls
but i'm facing tough odds here
god has basically abandoned me
i'm all alone with no prospects don't
make this harder than it is
well lorpa
she is a good girl
and at this point she realizes that
naomi's serious so she does what she's
told and she heads home
back to her mom
and back to her gods
but ruth
ruth is a little bit more stubborn
she's not about to let naomi go home
alone so the text says that she clings
to her
she clings to her while naomi's trying
to pry her off
look she says orpah did as she was told
she went back to her place she went back
to her people and frankly it's time for
you to do the same
go home
but ruth will not give up
she won't give up she says don't make me
leave you please
don't make me turn my back on you
look where you go i will go where you
stay i'll
stay your country is home to me now
and your god is my god
i'm staying with you until death and
beyond
god is my witness
i'm not gonna leave you
well now naomi realizes that there's
nothing she can do to shake this girl
and it makes her mad
if she can't shake her well she's going
to do the next best thing
she's just not gonna talk to her
did you notice it said she spoke to her
no more
so off they go to bethlehem
one
walking quickly and angrily and the
other following behind and not a
conversation to be had
now when they get to bethlehem well the
whole town is talking about them and
everybody comes out to see them the
women in particular
naomi they say naomi is that you
they can't believe that she came home
and they gather around her
naomi instead of saying hey
good to see you hi how are you this is
my daughter-in-law ruth
or any of the other niceties one of us
might say well naomi goes on the
offensive
don't call me naomi she says
call me mara
a name that means bitter
because the lord has made my life very
bitter
see when i left here my life was great
it was perfect and full but god took
everything away from me
everything i loved god took away from me
why would you call me naomi a name that
means sweet and pleasant
when god has given me nothing that is
sweet and pleasant
god's decided to punish me
for some reason
now you can imagine everyone standing
there looking at her as the narrator
ends chapter one with the words so naomi
returned from moab accompanied by ruth
the mo bitis her daughter-in-law
arriving in bethlehem as the barley
season was beginning
the book is called ruth
but it seems to be a story about naomi
doesn't it
naomi who pushed one daughter-in-law
away and is not speaking to the second
naomi a woman who is wallowing in
self-pity and the gross unfairness of
life
wondering why me why me none of this is
my fault
naomi who was sweet and pleasant when
everything was going her way
but in the midst of calamity has become
angry because she believes god has done
all these terrible things to her
in the midst of naomi's tragedies
the supposed main character ruth seems
to get lost in the shuffle
she's just along for the ride isn't she
and it would be easy
to dismiss her
just as naomi does
and that's precisely you see the point
that the narrator is trying to make here
because the fact of the matter is
whether we like it or not whether we
admit it or not we are a whole lot
like naomi
when tragedy befalls us or when bad
things happen to us we like her we begin
to focus solely on ourselves
we can't see past those things
we can't see past our own pain
did you notice excuse me did you notice
that naomi never gave one thought
to the fact that orpah
and ruth
had both lost husbands too
she didn't seem to think about the fact
that neither orpah or ruth had children
despite 10 years of marriage
that in fact orpa and ruth were both in
the same situation she was in
she was so convinced
that everything was all about her that
she was totally unaware of the tragedies
that were befalling other people
and in the midst of her bitterness she's
unable to see
the grace that has been given to her
see the truth is like naomi it's it's
easy for us to sink into anger and
bitterness when we're in pain isn't it
so easy to wallow in what we see is the
unfairness of life so easy to believe
that god has it out for us
despite what we say we might believe
when we are hurting our theology becomes
a whole lot
like naomi's
believed that everything had happened to
her because god had turned against her
so it's so important for us to notice
what the narrator of the story is trying
to tell us because what they're trying
to tell us is we are wrong
we are wrong
see we we might our eyes might be closed
to god's presence and we might think we
know our story but we may be missing
something
big
because in the middle of pain and grief
of anger and bitterness there is a woman
named ruth
ruth
the one naomi ignores
the one who seems to be a millstone
around her neck
ruth who refuses to be shaken off or put
aside ruth who although grieving
walks quietly
beside her mother-in-law
ruth who despite her mother-in-law's
treatment
stands by her faithfully
ruth
who seems to have a much different idea
of who god is
see we
like naomi
are so often blind
and the narrator is trying to tell us it
is so important that we look and see our
roots
see the people who are standing beside
us in the midst of tragedy in the midst
of pain those people who are shining
god's light
quietly reflecting god's love for us
they're quiet
they're unassuming
who is your ruth
when you are in pain when you are
suffering
are you seeing your ruth because i
guarantee
she's there
she might be in the congregation
she might be your next-door neighbor
but god
is and will send a ruth
to walk beside you
and it's so important
that we understand it's a gift
it's a gift that we don't deserve
let's see it's god's grace
it's god's loving grace
unnoticed
my friends i encourage every one of you
to look for your ruth
and i encourage you to listen to god
because god may be asking you to be a
ruth
to stand beside someone who's hurting
to let them know
they're loved
they're precious
even if they are acting
like naomi
that's a better word than i was going to
use
i pray that
god will impress it upon each of our
hearts
so that we might go out into the world
and share god's grace
with each person we meet
in the name of the father and of the son
and of the holy spirit
amen
i'm moving from one place to the other
now
so my friends i i want to say that i'm
just always so thrilled that you all are
celebrating communion so often it's just
this huge
wonder and delight to me so i'm so
pleased today to um
to say a blessing over the communion
in the methodist church we
we have a little liturgy we do and so i
want to make sure and do the prayer if i
can
would you pray with me please
oh god we praise you for you are love
and out of love you made us in love's
image
you created us as beloved children but
our pride
well it marred our loving likeness and
separated us from you and from one
another so you shape the laws of nature
the course of history the tongues of
prophets and the hope of nations
to restore us to your holy self
and so with your people on earth and all
the company of heaven we praise your
name and join in their unending unending
hymn seeing holy holy holy lord
god of power and might heaven and earth
are full of your glory hosanna in the
highest
blessed is he who comes in the name of
the lord hosanna in the highest
holy are you oh god and blessed is your
son jesus christ for by the power of the
holy spirit he is god in flesh incarnate
love the i am
who is one with us
anointed to proclaim a oneness with god
and restore our oneness to god he
selflessly surrendered his life to death
upon a cross
in his resurrection he gave birth to the
church
making us one body
fit for kingdom building
whereby all of creation will be restored
on the night in which he gave himself up
for us our lord took bread
he gave thanks to you oh god he broke
the bread gave it to his disciples and
said take eat
this is my body
which is given for you do this in
remembrance of me
and when the supper was over he took the
cup he gave thanks to you
gave it to his disciples and said drink
from this all of you this is my blood of
the new covenant poured out for you and
for many for the forgiveness of sins do
this as often as you drink of it
in remembrance of me
and so in remembrance of these your
mighty acts in christ jesus we offer
ourselves oh god
in praise and thanksgiving as a holy and
living sacrifice in union with christ's
offering for us
we pray that you would pour out your
holy spirit on us gathered here and on
these gifts of bread and wine
make them be for us the body and blood
of christ that we may be for the world
the body of christ
redeemed by his blood
by your spirit
oh god make us one
one with christ one with each other and
one in ministry to all the world until
christ comes again in final victory
and we feast at his heavenly banquet
through your son jesus christ and the
holy spirit and your holy church all
honor and glory is yours almighty god
now and forever
amen
my friends i bid you come this is the
table not
of the church
but of the lord
it is made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more
so come
you who have much faith in you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
because it's the lord that invites you
here
it is his will those who want him should
meet him here so come
come to the table
amen
so
[Music]
do
and sometimes it's so easy to be
consumed by what's going on in our own
lives that we don't see
anyone else around us and
i can definitely confess that i have
been there before
and
i'm sure we all have i'm i mean i would
be surprised if you guys didn't think of
your own moments
where you've felt so consumed
by whatever was going on around you that
it is easy to forget that there are
other people
in our lives dealing with their own
things so
we're going to close out with this song
it's called come to the table and it's
been i mean
y'all could we ask for a better title
for our
congregation but truly it's been one
that has kind of marked this journey for
us as a church from its
birth and for those of you who don't
know the story of the table at some
point you need to hear it because
um
you'll see these lyrics in a completely
new and fresh way this is truly kind of
our prayer
that this would be a place where we have
eyes to see each other where there would
be space for all of our stories
and so i pray that we can kind of
internalize it tonight these lyrics and
make them personal where we are making
room where we're inviting each other
not just to this table not just this
table but to our tables in our lives
come you know
there's space there's room there's
there's room for me to take my eyes off
of myself and to see you
and to make space for you
so if you guys want to stand with us
let's kind of close out a little bit
more communal tonight and all sing this
song together as kind of our
anthem our prayer
come all proud
[Music]
come on
from near and
far
[Music]
we saved you a seat
every race
[Music]
to a table full of
dreams
[Music]
day
just how many
[Music]
loved
oh
[Music]
come now come
comedy
[Music]
we're ready
is
[Music]
as the kingdom of priests
thank you worship team that was i love
that song i don't know what it is i just
love that song
also thank you denise um it was a
blessing glad that you were here
just couple reminders um if you are a
visitor we are thrilled that you're here
there are some um welcome cards at the
very back there's a small little table
as you walk out that door
we would just like to
have not just uh your name just a little
bit of information about you just be
able to say thanks for being here
and just be able to reach out to you
then also if you're again this is a
quick reminder the summer rama sign up
is at the back as well so if you
wouldn't mind if that's something you're
interested in sign up for that
um and then also um if you're if you can
call the table home and you feel glad to
support our ministry financially
of course you can do that there's also a
box in the mac you can do that as well
or you do that online you can do that
through our website
so with that being said i'm going to
send you out with this blessing
so you
are a child of god
you are a child of god
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
us yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything
in between
go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved
you are worthy and you are accepted
just as you are
and go
filled with god's holy spirit and the
desire to extend these same gifts
and unconditional love to everyone you
come in contact with thank you
[Music]
we're ready
as a kingdom of priests
[Music]
you